[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
hoy en el marco de la sesión número 76
de la asamblea general de las naciones
unidas donde los temas de la mayoría de
los discursos han sido el cambio
climático y la pandemia pero también en
esta reunión de alto nivel ha habido
tiempo para reproches como el que ha
traído el presidente de bolivia luis
arce contra la organización de estados
américanos buenas tardes señor
gracias compañeros usted planteaba que
la oea no es suficiente está marcando
divisiones dentro de los de los países
latinoamericanos y que además estaría
detrás del golpe de estado del 2019 y
plantea la celac a la comunidad de
estados latinoamericanos y caribeños
porque cree que la celac puede funcionar
y no la oea
cuando fue creada la celac a los
orígenes los fundamentos para crear la
escena era pues que la web ya no cumplía
a esa altura estamos hablando los
desafíos y encaraba lo que nosotros
necesitamos como país de américa latina
porque la oea tenía una fuerte
injerencia de otros países que no tienen
no están muy relacionados ni conocen la
región por lo tanto no estamos diciendo
nada más que fortalece a la celular que
fue el organismo que todos creamos y
donde hay de diversas corrientes
políticas de gobiernos se puede llegar a
acuerdos en temas que nos nos atañen a
todos en la región para nosotros la oea
ha jugado un rol absolutamente
nefasto en el golpe de estado del 2019
si bien el gobierno boliviano en esa
época viaje a un acuerdo para hacer una
auditoría
de las del proceso electoral de octubre
tenía que entregarse un informe final
que ni la auditoría ni el informe final
hasta ahora se conoce que se conoce un
informe preliminar que no está acordado
que no era auditoría y tuve el detonante
de todo lo que en bolivia se produjo en
noviembre de 2019 y que fue la chispa
que inició el golpe de estado
entonces hay 38 muertes en bolivia
fuimos exiliados detenidos y enjuiciados
torturados
muchos dirigentes
por el golpe de estado quien más
respondes eso es lo que nos preguntamos
pero el papel de la cee la que al final
es la unidad y brasil salió de esa
organización en el 2020 y chile ni
siquiera asistió a la última reunión
realmente usted cree que une a la
américa latina bueno esas son posiciones
de los países porque no fue el espíritu
de creación se recordará también se creó
el grupo de lima
es decir yo creo que es el peor es en el
que la ciudad se crea en un clima tan
tan donde tanto gente de derecha como
gente de izquierda conforman la escena
para objetivos comunes ahí participamos
todos en la construcción del celular
en esta ocasión si brasil se sale si
chile quiere ir bueno están mostrando
simplemente los actuales gobiernos la
poca importancia que le dan a la región
hasta cuándo va a estar las presidentas
jeanine áñez en prisión bueno hasta que
la justicia dé su veredicto
alguien tiene que responder responder de
los 38 muertos que más responden ha sido
nuestro gobierno del movimiento al
socialismo en los 38 muertos no ha sido
del golpe de estado
cuando ella era presidenta ella firmé un
decreto
autorizando las fuerzas de manzanares a
reprimir al pueblo boliviano de eso
tenemos 38 muertos miles de heridos
encarcelados
exiliar tortura
enjuiciados sin el debido proceso ella
hoy tiene el debido proceso se está
respetando todos los derechos más lo que
ya no es
yo cuando llegue a bolivia para ser
candidato ella me estaban esperando para
restarles recuerda usted quien dijo algo
sobre eso a nosotros no nos mueve la
venganza a nosotros nos mueve el interés
por esa injusticia para esa gente y cómo
se va a garantizar ese juicio imparcial
de cara a la comunidad internacional que
gana vida se van a dar los jueces los
fiscales los vocales de la corte suprema
de justicia en bolivia en este momento
fueron los mismos lo que nos está
beneficiando a nosotros cuál es el
límite para su salud para que se permita
que esté monitoreada por servicios
sanitarios está siendo un monitoreo de
todos los días ha recibido visitas de
médicos especialistas se lo ha llevado a
clínicas especiales todo todo
no existe usted no puede afirmar en este
momento que ella está delicada
en base a que informe médico afirma
ustedes no creo que usted tenga nosotros
confiamos en lo que está haciendo la
justicia de bolivia en los médicos que
la tienen y nadie puede afirmar de
buenas a primeras que esta delicada
enferma o que está dañada a su salida no
le preocupa que la comunidad
internacional que tanto ha pedido que se
le ponga en libertad se aleje un poco de
bolivia hay nueva información de lo que
estuvo de lo que estudian de quienes
estuvieron participando del golpe de
estado haya al menos no se sabe dos país
argentina en con el sido macri y el
señor de limones involucrados con el
tema de enviar al gobierno golpista
armamento y otras cosas
entonces de qué comunidades estamos
hablando de la que colaboraron con el
golpe de estado
el ánimo unión europea está involucrada
es su representante el cubo un papel
nefasto en el
momento del golpe de estado yo lo viví
yo estuve ahí
la iglesia
estaba el embajador de brasil
en la reunión donde toda la derecha
golpista que estaba ahí estaban por
elegir a quién a quién iba a ser el
próximo presente que tiene que ser el
embajador de brasil en la definición del
próximo presidente si valía esa reunión
no sé qué poder tener quiénes eran los
actores estaban definiendo quién iba a
ser el próximo presidente de bolivia
cuál es el papel que juega a los
presidente evo morales en su gobierno
muchos dicen que estaría detrás que
sería un poco a la persona que mueve los
hilos detrás bueno eso siempre lo dice
quien en los partidos de derecha porque
tratan de confundir a las olas el
compañero evo desde que llegó al país lo
que ha hecho es tomar control de lo que
es hoy presidente el ex presidente del
movimiento al socialismo y psp y él está
cumpliendo las funciones de presidente
del más del partido político y luízar se
está cumpliendo las funciones de
presidente del estado plurinacional por
eso usted me está entrevistando a mí y
no está entrevistando al compañero evo
morales
como influye en su gobierno los cambios
que estamos viendo en el conosur de los
países latinoamericanos en brasil va a
haber elecciones
que posiblemente hay un cambio
ideológico hemos visto también en en
chile- que posiblemente también haya un
cambio de dirección ideológica como le
va a beneficiar o perjudicar esto a
bolivia
bueno es son decisiones de los países
del pueblo de cada uno de los países
nosotros nos vamos a inmiscuir nosotros
respetamos la autodeterminación de los
países vamos a trabajar con cualquiera
que salga electo de las urnas en
elecciones
como es el caso del profesor castillo
como es el caso del presidente
ecuatoriano que ha salido de las urnas
nosotros vamos a trabajar con ellos
independiente independientemente pero
que sean democráticamente elegidos los
datos acerca de la pandemia en su país
son muy positivos ha habido una
desescalada de casos nuevos en las
últimas 14 semanas y además su ministro
de salud asegura que hay vacunas para
todos esto no pasa en el resto de
américa latina que es lo que ha hecho
bolivia
nosotros desde el primer día inclusive
desde la campaña denunciábamos
que los países desarrollados han
acaparado las vacunas y la producción de
vacunas en el mundo
hemos denunciado este hecho hemos pedido
inclusive que se liberen las patentes
que se liberen los derechos de propiedad
para que todos puedan producir la vacuna
porque este es un tema que afecta a
todos la vacuna y la salud no puede ser
una mercancía más en el sistema
capitalista no puede ser esto la
pandemia está demostrando que el
capitalismo salvaje está presenta
inclusiva está en la salud y eso pone en
riesgo a la vida misma de toda la
humanidad la mortalidad del comb y 19
bajo el gobierno de facto fue más del 6%
nos bajamos a todos como lo bajaron
cuáles fueron las mecanismo esta
estrategia fue muy simple no lo que
nosotros hicimos con tres pilares
primero
de conseguir las pruebas mantiene unas
sales rápidas para distribuirlas
gratuitamente a toda la población y
distribuimos a los municipios a las
gobernaciones cuando se hace el test uno
prevé pues no cité a los sitios y sale
el test puede medicar se puede aislar
después de muchas cosas y ese fue el
segundo paso y el tercero fue la vacuna
nosotros salimos a comprar en un
escenario donde todas las vacunas
estaban vendidas de cloro hasta el 2025
nosotros hicimos negociaciones
bilaterales hablamos con el presidente
putin hablamos con el presidente si
simple
personalmente para que nos puedan dotar
de algunas vacunas se abrieron espacios
entramos al sistema cobas lo que muchos
países solamente confiaron en el sistema
cobas como lamentablemente si uno se
confiaba en el sistema como no
hubiéramos resuelto el problema nunca
hemos logrado vacunar y además con
diversificación de vacunas para todos
para todo el pueblo boliviano que
estamos en índices
aceptables pero no estamos satisfecho
todos estamos exigiendo a nuestro
ministro de salud que tenemos que llegar
a un horizonte más alto es la única
manera de resolver los problemas de
salud de móvil señalarse el presidente
yo vayan a incluido bolivia en la lista
de países que no están haciendo digamos
los suficientes esfuerzos para luchar
contra el narcotráfico más allá de las
cifras que pueden diferir las que tiene
eeuu a las que tiene bolivia cuáles son
las acciones que arrebaten esta
afirmación bueno hay dos cosas primero
que el informe abarca gran parte de qué
año del 2020 y eso no lo dijeron
y evidentemente el 2020
ustedes deportes de brasil de paraguay
se han encontrado avioneta en el
gobierno de facto donde se recrudeció
donde empezó a evidentemente cosas raras
en el narcotráfico en el país y de
pronto en camino se incrementó se
incrementó y es evidente pero nosotros
lo vimos todos durante el gobierno de
facto una vez que un gobierno
democrático entra iniciamos nuestras
tareas de erradicación de la hoja de
coca lo que no se había hecho durante
todo el gobierno de facto lo interesante
es que los informes de eeuu nunca les
reclaman nada del narcotráfico al
gobierno de facto y solamente salen con
estos reportes y todo apunta al gobierno
nacional actual democráticamente elegido
así que no atribuyen al gobierno
nacional aspectos que corresponden al
gobierno
señor arte muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros hoy
cantaba